with coverts surging again and don't we
hate that across much of the country
some hospitals and clinics are using
some creative tactics you could say to
encourage kids to get their vaccinations
so for many young children the prospects
of rolling up a sleepwalk shot comes
with a big old heavy dose of anxiety
yeah it does jamie uk has visited a
southern california hospital where some
furry friends are helping tame some
frazzled nerves
[Music]
at rady children's hospital in san diego
the vaccination clinic is bringing in
the big dogs doesn't she look like a
stuffed animal yeah
on the day of our visit we found lucy a
golden doodle and tank a golden
retriever roaming the halls
they're ready to take on the tears and
fears you want him to do a trick for you
before you go
yeah okay
have you ever seen a dog crawl before
fear of needles is common in kids and
adolescents so these canines are
specially trained to comfort and cuddle
so much better five-year-old twins
camellia and monsterat are
immunocompromised they came for their
second dose of the covett
vaccine but the panic ended quickly
because the dogs helped them get past
the poke you're gonna be having fun so
good
yay oh
so sweet they were very nervous and they
didn't want to come back for the second
dose and the moment we entered and they
saw the dogs
they ran into it and they were more calm
seems like the dogs didn't just help the
kids but also helped you yeah they
helped us out the four of us
eight-year-old piper and her
five-year-old brother fox are also here
for their second shot i really like
animals and nature so it kind of
made me feel better
with
animals around
shots kind of hurt a little i used to
not like getting shots were you scared
to get your shot
a little bit
do you think every shot should come with
a dog
yeah because i think
it makes people more calm when they have
someone around lucy's going to help you
it was a scene repeated again and again
as the dogs provided distractions for
everyone want trying to come hang out
with you when you get your vaccine tank
and his owner dr susan duffy both work
in the hospital when she's not
volunteering with her pup dr duffy is a
critical care physician in the pediatric
icu the dogs help the kids relax
they help them feel like they're not at
a hospital and one little boy told me
today this is the best day ever i
skipped school and i got to meet tank
and lucy didn't think about the shop
yeah he's like i don't care about the
shot it was really sweet this is her
doctor costume volunteer melanie
jacobson says part of the fun is the
characters they create i see the kids
crying i see them anxious and then she
comes in and i tell them stories about
her i tell them how she likes to lie in
bed on the pillow
and they start laughing and they forget
about why they're here it's an idea
that's catching on in vaccine clinics
from boston to austin i didn't cry
back in san diego 15 four-legged friends
rotate shifts putting a positive spin on
the shot i think it will help long term
make them not afraid of getting their
shots and that's important very
important right they've got a lot more
to go jovana marcus says her sons were
dreading the day but that changed when
they met tank we didn't expect that
we didn't expect that so it was amazing
and we appreciate it and grateful to
man's best friend for sticking by their
side thanks hank for cbs mornings i'm
jamie yukis in san diego
[Music]
i wonder if the dogs are going them kids
crying again and i often wonder if dogs
like getting dressed up because it
really is very soothing and i see the
difference that they make and they have
a look on their face like they know they
look ridiculous but okay if you like it
you look good yeah you're saying the
dog's like get your sticky hands off me
i think the dog is wanting okay they're
crying again but the dogs are making a
difference and that really is a bottom
line yeah that's what it's all about
hank and lucy
make everything better that's right i
want to file my taxes this year and then
hug a dog have a lollipop